recently Elon Musk has been pushing for
Tesla to move its headquarters into
Texas or Nevada this decision has been
accelerated by the pandemic but is a
long time coming given California's high
state taxes plethora of regulations and
exuberant cost of labor and land as a
result a move to Texas or Nevada's more
business-friendly landscape is not very
surprising but this does bring up the
question why did Tesla and pretty much
every other tech company even lay roots
in Silicon Valley in the first place
while starting off new york actually
still has the most number of fortune 500
companies at 58 but this is largely
fueled by the financial industry in
which New York continues to largely
dominate with giants like JPMorgan Chase
and Goldman Sachs asked for the tech
industry however this has mostly been
between Texas and California for several
years now as they slightly edged each
other out anyways one of the main
appeals to California and specifically
Silicon Valley for the past few decades
is the demographic like New York
historically and more recently Dubai
most of the people who lived in Silicon
Valley had immigrated there the close
proximity to China and Japan attracted
many Asian immigrants to California who
often came from hard backgrounds
determined to improve the situation even
today California houses half of the
Asian population in the United States
the native population was by far the
minority generally when people have been
in their hometowns or even home
countries to start a new life in a
different place they are much more
motivated to learn work and grow they
are more likely to take a risk with the
startup that might go bankrupt the
following year and are willing to take a
lower salary in return for higher stock
bonus as a result the demographic of
people who lived here during the 1980s
and 90s were perfect for start-up
looking for hard-working risk takers the
only other place with this demographic
was New York but that was already super
congested with finance so tech company
settled for California moving on
California was the destination of many
wealthy young retirees including actors
celebrities and sports stars these guys
were often attracted to California by
the weather and lifestyle and though
these guys had retired from their
professions they were still young and
excited to invest in startups that had
the potential to take them to the next
level consequently Silicon Valley had
the two biggest ingredients for a
growing company success which are a
strong workforce and funding this is
what allowed for the initial boom of
tech companies such as HP Oracle Cisco
and Apple however as the immigrants in
Silicon Valley settled down a
kids the motivation to grow often died
out as people are simply satisfied with
their progress and situation similarly
as the government regulation tightened
and taxes increased California also
started losing at the financial appeal
as well evidently a lot of the original
appeal to Silicon Valley died down with
the turn of the millennium but this
didn't stop another tech boom in Silicon
Valley from occurring so what was the
accelerant for the second boom well the
thing is many Silicon Valley startups
are started by individuals who used to
work at the big giants for instance more
recently the founder of zoom video
technologies erawan used to work at
Cisco and WebEx before starting zoom
moreover many of these people starting
new companies had worked there for
decades as a result they already had
established families networks and
financial opportunities so it didn't
make sense for them to move out to a
different stage and start all over again
in their 40s or 50s furthermore even if
they were young and or willing to move
to a different state they didn't have a
choice
startups generally don't have the
resources to establish a base in a new
state and attract talented individuals
to the new state startups simply can't
afford to miss out on the best talent
around the world in the tech industry
already working in Silicon Valley
thus startups like Facebook and snapchat
continue to move into Silicon Valley
despite the drawbacks asked for the
larger companies they did see the upside
and relocating to different states with
more favorable business policies however
they too were simply far established in
Silicon Valley that any benefits are
moving to a new state were negligible in
comparison to the hassle of moving tens
of thousands of employees and building
new office complexes despite this many
tech companies did have their eye on
other states so they plan on expanding T
States rather than relocating altogether
and throughout the last 20 years many
tech companies did expand out to
California like Google Apple Microsoft
Intel Facebook and HP who all landed in
Texas
and along with them they brought
hundreds of thousands of tech workers
and financial capital into several
states outside of California likewise
these large companies have made it
possible for nearest startups to take
crews in other states
largely avoiding the pitfalls of Silicon
Valley so what started as a state with
the high population of immigrants and
rich individuals turn into breeding
grounds for early tech companies but
soon enough the con start away the pros
but despite this Silicon Valley had
become so established that new startups
couldn't thrive without the talent there
and large companies were simply too
established to move however with
expansion instead of upgrading complexes
in California or opening new complexes
in other California cities many
companies decided to expand into
different states with more favorable
business policies this has largely
diversified the tech industry across the
u.s. giving nura startups more options
but that's why Silicon Valley dominated
tech for so long
if you guys thought this video explained
the appeal for Silicon Valley over the
years well they made you drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]